Монументальна статуя Батьківщини-матері зустрічає усіх, хто прямує
з лівого берега Дніпра на правий.
Погляд скульптури спрямований у бік Москви, у руках - меч і щит
із гербом Радянського Союзу. Чимало киян настільки звикли
до цього символу СРСР, що і не помічають його.
Хоча і живемо недалеко, і бачимо статую щодня, але не помічали,
не задумувалися. Можливо, тому що не мислимо такими кліше.
Ну, я просто не бачила там герб Радянського Союзу… А герб України нашої є там?
У додатку "Дія" триває опитування - що робити з радянським гербом?
Є три варіанти: залишити, як є, зняти герб СРСР і залишити щит чистим,
або ж замінити герб на тризуб. Проголосували вже більше 600 тисяч людей.
Ось які відповіді ми почули від киян.
Я вважаю, що треба вже давно було його зняти і замінити його на герб України,
тому що він взагалі не відповідає дійсності, і ніколи не відповідав.
Це символ Києва і хотілося б, щоб замість радянського герба був тризуб.
Напевне, його не потрібно знімати. Тому що це наша історія. Її ж не зміниш.
Можна було б, щоб наш герб був… Потрібно обов'язково, щоб був,
бо це асоціація з радянським часом, тому що Батьківщина-мати…
Хто його знає, чи варто з історією боротися.
Деякі коментатори в соцмережах навіть закликають знести пам'ятник
як радянський символ. Очільник Інституту національної пам'яті Антон Дробович
наголошує, що це дорого. До того ж, монумент має статус історичної пам'ятки.
Навіть у законі про декомунізацію є виняток для мистецьких пам'яток,
створених до набуття законом чинності.
Порядок має бути такий - опитування, зміна статусу і тоді вже всілякі дії.
Тому що дехто навіть каже, от давайте дозволимо її на металобрухт розібрати
- люди, які таке говорять, вони взагалі не мають уявлення, що це величезний розмір.
А по-друге, що це частина меморіального комплексу.
Колишній голова Інституту нацпам'яті Володимир В'ятрович говорить,
що не шкодував би, якби статую демонтували.
Але з наявних варіантів у опитуванні схиляється до того, аби щит Батьківщини-матері
був чистим. На думку В'ятровича, залишати герб СРСР - незаконно,
а замінити тризубом - недоречно.
Я скептично ставлюся до ідеї прикрасити цей щит Батьківщини-матері
тризубом, тому що цей пам'ятник, ця монументальна металева
скульптура є радянською, і жодні спроби її українізувати ні до чого не призведуть,
вона залишиться радянською. Так само як я вважав недоречним,
слава Богу цього вже немає, коли намагалися натягти шаровари
на Володимира Ілліча Леніна чи намалювати йому шевченківські вуса.
Монумент Батьківщині-матері - це дійсно яскравий зразок радянського мистецтва
соцреалізму. Так відзначено на сайті музею історії України у Другій світовій війні,
до якого належить пам'ятка. Статую звели в 1981 році.
Зварювали з окремих листів сталі. Монтували за допомогою величезних кранів.
Співробітники музею розповідають, що один із кранів не встигли прибрати
до приїзду Леоніда Брєжнєва на відкриття скульптури, тож машину розпиляли на місці.
Нині на першому поверсі монумента - музей. Вище - два ліфти і сходи,
якими можна піднятися до щита скульптури.
Для багатьох Батьківщина-мати - один із символів Києва.
А ще це найвища монументальна скульптура Європи. До верхівки меча
її висота сягає 102 метри. І це навіть вище, ніж Статуя Свободи в Нью-Йорку.
З найвищої точки добре видно, що сумнозвісний радянський герб
- невід'ємна частина конструкції щита. Про його демонтаж говорять не вперше,
надто після ухвалення закону про декомунізацію в 2015 році,
хоча це складний проєкт. Колишній очільник інституту нацпам'яті Володимир В'ятрович
розповідає, що за його каденції питання дійшло до етапу створення робочої групи.
Найімовірніший варіант, який розглядався для демонтажу радянського герба,
йшлося про накриття зверху додатковими металевими пластинами,
щоб пам'ятник не втратив конструктивних особливостей своїх,
які б могли призвести до його падіння. Тобто питання доходило
вже до практичної площини, але, на жаль, вочевидь, забракло часу,
забракло фінансового ресурсу, тому це питання залишилося невирішеним.
За словами нинішнього голови Інституту нацпам'яті Антона Дробовича,
розглядаються кілька варіантів демонтажу радянського символу.
Дорожчі і складніші - знімати весь щит будівельними кранами,
або розбирати його на частини за допомогою риштувань.
Більш реалістичним Антон Дробович вважає інше рішення.
Найбільш простий інженерний шлях - це зсередини, посекційно,
це ж не суцільний герб, він зроблений з сталевих листів.
Між іншим, завод, на якому виготовляли ці листи і ця марка сталі,
ще до війни точно працював цей цех і випускав, і по одному листу сталі
- знімається і спускається. І баланс не змінюється, тому що на кожен знятий лист сталі
або піднімається відповідна вага піску, або такий самий лист сталі.
Оцінити вартість такого задуму поки неможливо - спершу треба дочекатися
результатів опитування. Потім скласти проєктну документацію,
затвердити її на державному рівні. Але йдеться про не один мільйон гривень.
За словами Антона Дробовича, до війни до нього навіть зверталися дві приватні компанії,
які готові спонсорувати демонтаж герба.
У музеї, який відповідає за збереження Батьківщини-матері, погоджуються з тим,
що настав час позбутися радянського символу.
Директор музею закликає покладатися на думку молоді. За його словами,
статуя вже давно не сприймається молодшим поколінням як радянська пам'ятка.
Натомість для багатьох вона стала символом незламності України.
Скульптура з перших днів війни зображалася з головою Путіна,
що Батьківщина-мати тримає голову Путіна.
Дуже багато інших надзвичайно цікавих мемів, які в лаконічній формі
і яскраво демонструють сприйняття нашими сучасниками.
І на моє глибоке переконання, це далеко від тих тлумачень, які у запеклій боротьбі
біля комп'ютера, у коментарях продукує старше покоління,
зашорене і заідеологізоване певними штампами і догмами.
В Інституті нацпам'яті певні, що в нинішньому опитуванні більшість українців
підтримають або демонтаж герба, або заміну його на тризуб.
За словами Антона Дробовича, у такому разі роботи можуть початися
вже в першій половині 2023 року. Але за умови,
що ситуація на фронті дозволить займатися історичними питаннями.